[Applauso]
la solita infografica sul sole
formativo questa forse è la slide più
usata in assoluto quando si parla di
connessioni vero no
bene sono d'accordo con voi perché io
sono qui venuto a dire che noi non
abbiamo un problema di sovraccarico
informativo
ci piacerebbe ci piacerebbe prenderci
per dei filosofi degli appartenenti alla
scuola di atene negli intellettuali che
vanno in rete
e il primo ed unico problema che hanno
avere troppo informazioni da codificare
da mettere in ordine da capirne le
priorità magari fosse così non è il
sovraccarico informativo il nostro
problema è un altro tipo di sovraccarico
e sapete qual è il fatto che questi
contenuti non se ne stanno lì inerti ma
ci arrivano già litigati pensateci bene
no ci arrivano già con una reazione una
recriminazione una lamentela di qualcuno
che è connesso con noi siamo in una
situazione per cui il sovraccarico è di
differenze cioè noi ci ritroviamo vicino
a noi nei nostri spazi online la
differenza nel modo di vedere il mondo
dell'altro continuamente che si sta
lamentando di qualcosa ed è l'effetto
che io chiamo della diversità aumentata
come nella realtà aumentata
attraverso il digitale noi vediamo degli
elementi del mondo intorno a noi che si
sottolineano band emergono i nostri
occhi in maniera più evidente la
diversità aumentata fa sì che siamo
tutti più vicini
entriamo in contatto più spesso e più
intensamente con la differenza degli
altri
e allora qual è quella situazione
sociale tipica direi simbolica nel
momento in cui noi pensiamo delle
persone che stanno vicine pensiamo ai
vicini
la riunione di condominio è questa
l'immagine secondo me più propria della
nostra connessione la nostra è una
riunione di condominio generalizzata in
cui ognuno impegnato a fare che cosa
a difendere in qualche modo il suo
spazio vitale come nelle riunioni
condominio i suoi interessi perché
perché sente minacciati i suoi spazi
dall'altro che la vede in modo
differente perché accade questo perché
ogni volta che emerge la differenza
dell'altro e ci arriva vicina che cosa
accade accade una messa alla prova cioè
il problema è che appena l'altro ci dice
le sue idee
le nostre non sono più le idee unica in
circolazione e improvvisamente siamo
costretti a fare che cosa
a metterle alla prova a vedere se quelle
idee reggono lo stesso nonostante
l'altro che è arrivato con le sue cosa
facciamo quindi quello che si fanno le
linee condominio litighiamo
sapete cosa serve il litigio e litigio
serve esattamente a riprodurre quella di
stanza in cui io voglio rimettere la
differenza dell'altro siccome non posso
mettere una distanza fisica perché le
sue differenze mi arrivano comunque
nella connessione mette una distanza
attraverso che cosa la rottura della
relazione con lui
litigare è l'operazione più facile
primitiva istintiva per smettere di
confrontarsi
allora io studio e litigi da molti anni
ho accumulato e studiato centinaia di
migliaia di interazioni scomposte a
livello internazionale e alla fine
questa mole gigantesca di dati di questa
mole gigantesca ne ho fatto un
infografica che riassumesse lo stato di
queste di questi litigi e sono venuto
qui al the text di ascoli a presentarla
ecco a voi lo stato del dibattito a
livello internazionale adesso a parte
gli scherzi in realtà in questa
bellissima vignetta c'è tutto quello che
serve da sapere sui litigi perché il
primo effetto del litigio è quello che
vediamo il litigio serve ad uscire dal
tema quando litighi smetti di dover
affrontare l'argomento da cui era
partito il confronto e noi lo sappiamo
fare benissimo abbiamo soprattutto tre
modalità la prima sei tu che non ci
arrivi
avete presente quando in una discussione
la prima cosa che cercano di fare andare
sul personale
mettiamo in mezzo una caratteristica
persona dell'altro per dire questa
inficia la discussione non posso più
discutere con te lo scopo è quello di
smettere di discutere
altra strategia è una vergogna non posso
credere che tu abbia scritto una cosa
del genere ma ti pare che dici così
prendiamo un principio morale su cui ci
mettiamo come su un palco per giudicare
da una posizione morale superiore
l'indennità di quello che sta dicendo
l'altro altra strategia per dire non
continuiamo a discutere se ci pensate
allo scopo è sempre quello
allora poi se non riusciamo a dare
nessun personale né rivolgerci ai
principi che cosa facciamo
facciamo questo stai forse dicendo che
due punti aperte le virgolette
riformulazione del pensiero dell'altro
in base ai miei criteri così è più
facilmente criticabile ovviamente
travisato in modo tale che io lo possa
maneggiare e criticare con più facilità
di nuovo di fronte all'argomento diverso
dell'altro io non accetto il confronto
ma lo evito
ma c'è un altro effetto dei litigi che
si vede in questa vignetta e che litigi
sono trasparenti noi quando litighiamo
siamo come quei due paperotti lì viene
fuori tutti quelli che assistono al
litigio si accorgono delle nostre
fragilità nei nostri dubbi delle nostre
mancanze
quante volte abbiamo visto o forse siamo
stati noi stessi persone colte esperte
che stimiamo fare veramente la figura
dei bambini mentre litigano no e questo
ci dice una cosa importante
noi quando discutiamo non facciamo
scambi di idee non siamo gli
intellettuali della scuola di atene a
parte che anche quelli della squadra
tiene se le davano di santa ragione
quindi non siamo quegli intellettuali
non è uno scambio di idee ogni
discussione per quanto piccola in realtà
uno scontro tra mondi noi nelle nostre
discussioni mettiamo tutti noi stessi
per quello quando litighiamo si vede
quanto siamo fragili
pensiamo al dilemma per eccellenza il
bicchiere mezzo vuoto e mezzo pieno come
in tutti i dilemmi nessuno affronta un
dilemma per stabilire la quantità
d'acqua presente nel bicchiere
ma nel dire la sua posizione ci dice
cosa pensa degli altri cosa pensa del
mondo cosa pensa della realtà e qual è
il posto che lui si vuole ritagliare che
significato dalle cose a cosa da un
valore ci mette tutto se stesso
noi in ogni discussione mettiamo tutti
noi stessi per quanto le cose siano
piccole è così importante discutere
perché dentro le discussioni c'è la
nostra identità e il nostro posto nel
mondo
e allora torniamo alla linea di
condominio generalizzata come si
prendono le decisioni
nelle riunioni di condominio per alzata
di mano e nell'area di condominio e
generalizzate così è l'atteggiamento che
abbiamo oggi la cosa pensiamo ogni volta
che comunità
ilike le alzate di mano quanto questa
mia o messaggio otterrà consenso pensate
al sondaggismo eccessivo
prima di proporre qualcosa un'idea una
soluzione quello che faccio è capire
quanto sarà recepita e accettata dalla
gente quanto consenso susciterà qual è
il problema in questo è il sogno della
comunicazione felice fateci caso devo
dire una cosa talmente bene talmente ben
confezionata talmente che risponda ai
desideri degli altri che otterrò di
metterli tutti d'accordo la
comunicazione felice che mette tutti
d'accordo
ebbene per fortuna la connessione con la
sua diversità aumentata ci sta
costringendo ad abbandonare questa
illusione
la comunicazione felice che mette tutti
d'accordo non esiste per due motivi 1 il
consenso non durerà all'infinito anzi
come vediamo bene oggi a dei cicli
sempre più brevi sono fiammate che poi
cambiano ma comunque il dissenso delle
mani che non si sono alzate a tuo è mio
favore verrà fuori avrà il suo spazio
entrerà nei nostri spazi perché siamo
vicini allora dalla comunicazione felice
che vuole l'accordo del consenso
dobbiamo passare alla disputa felice
cioè siamo capaci di comunicare nel
disaccordo nel dissenso come si fa
beh dobbiamo perdere questa visione cioè
dobbiamo smettere di continuare a vedere
ma anzi di mani quanti mazzi di mani
ognuno riesce a far alzare e
incominciare a vedere ciascuna mano
incominciare a vedere cioè lì dentro
dentro quella conversazione ogni mano
come si alza e perché e se sa spiegare
se si alza se sa fare la differenza
in quella riunione di condominio
generalizzata e guardate che è tutto
nella nostra mano è tutto qui in
cominciare da quello che ci suggerisce
per esempio il primo tiro al mignolo il
più corto che ci dice se tu a entrare
una discussione facendo la differenza
disputando felicemente la prima cosa che
ti devi ricordare quel poco che sei quel
poco che sai che conosci che fa parte
delle tue esperienze se porti quello se
è in grado di discutere con tutti quando
invece noi ci magnifique chiamo quando
noi facciamo delle difese di ufficio di
cose che non sono nostre andiamo a
litigare
perché ciò che non è nostro non sappiamo
difenderlo quindi se io sono ridurre il
mio perimetro riconoscere chi sono e
cosa so ea metterle una discussione
posso discutere con tutti anche con i
più ostili
il secondo dito l'anulare che io non
riesco a tenere dritto scusate è quello
dell'anello nuziale ci ricorda dei
legami ci ricorda che una discussione
non è uno scambio di idee tra
intellettuali ma è una questione di
costruzione o distruzione dei legami e
per dissentire se noi vogliamo stare nel
disaccordo con qualcun altro anche
questa è una relazione da curare perché
sennò l'altro si sgancia e se si sgancia
non possiamo di sentire con lui e allora
sarà questo livello del legame che ci
porterà a curare bene le parole per non
farlo andar via per stare lì in quel
dissenso e qui ci aiuta il terzo dito
che non ha bisogno di grandi commenti ce
lo spiega da sé che se passiamo alle
parolacce all'aggressione a farci forti
in una discussione in realtà siamo
debolissimi perché l'effetto del dito
medio che a volte in parole
elegantissime che usiamo è bravissimo ad
alzare il dito medio
senza nessuna parolaccia ma con
un'aggressione interna quello che
diciamo
l'effetto del dito medio è solo uno
tappare le orecchie dell'altro e ci
rende debolissimi nel nostro dissenso
diamo la scusa del litigio anche
all'altro e smettiamo di discutere poi
c'è l'indice l'indice è quello che
osserviamo continuamente mentre l'altro
ci sta indicando la luna cosa ci ricorda
l'indice che dobbiamo rimanere sul tema
e sull'argomento
cioè se a noi sembra che lui stia
indicando male la luna dobbiamo parlare
di dov'è la luna non dobbiamo dirgli
indichi male perché quelle andare di
nuovo sul personale e ripartire sul
litigio la vera capacità di disputare
felicemente e rimanere a parlare
dell'argomento
infine il pollice il pollice e quello
che ci piace tenere così i like che ci
piace ricevere i like che ci piace
mettere bene questo pollice lo dobbiamo
rivolgere da un'altra parte e da questa
parte va rivolto perché nella riunione
di condominio generalizzata è tutto
troppo intenso e serio ogni discussione
diventa una discussione dal punto di
vista esistenziale fondamentale
facciamo guerre su questioni che sono
davvero relative facciamo guerre e
terribili su cose su cui sinceramente si
possono avere tranquillamente bisogno
diverse allora una delle cose più
importanti oggi da maturare è l'auto
aironi a e che cos'è l'auto ronnie ha la
capacità di distacco da se stessi la
capacità di guardarsi da fuori come si
fa a guardarsi da fuori ora oggi la
tecnologia guardateci offre
un'esperienza fondamentale che tutti
abbiamo fatto almeno una volta nella
vita
sono sicuro che ve la ricordate avete
preso il vostro smartphone
avete trovato una cosa da fotografare
avete aperto la fotocamera ed era girata
dalla parte sbagliata e improvvisamente
avete visto la vostra faccia da fuori
sapete che questo non ci succede con gli
specchi perché prima di specchiarci
prima di andare davanti a uno specchio
noi sempre abbiamo quella frazione di
secondo in cui facciamo una faccio una
faccia plausibile anche di prima mattina
quando abbiamo gli occhi gonfi capelli
comunque c'è quella frazione di secondo
di autostima che ci rimette in sesto e
quindi vediamo una faccia già preparata
quelli con la velocità retina display
retroilluminato hd 4k
non si scappa quella è la nostra faccia
vista da fuori
allora questa esperienza che ci dà la
tecnologia dobbiamo fare tesoro perché
noi in ogni discussione
dovremmo ricordarci il self involontario
cioè prima di rispondere prima di dare
guerra rispostona che ci sembra
sistemare la situazione prima di dire
quelle cose
proviamo a guardarci da fuori che faccia
abbiamo con un bel self involontario è
questo
guardate che ci dona due poteri enormi
per la disputa felice il primo potere e
il potere di lasciar cadere è un potere
gigantesco di fronte alle provocazioni
dell'altro di fronte alla parte
aggressiva delle sue parole essere
capaci di lasciarla perdere non
considerarla perché se lo facciamo
possiamo capire se nelle parole
dell'altro
nonostante le parti disfunzionali c'è
qualcosa di significativo
e se quello lo agganciamo ridiamo fiato
la discussione anche quando sembrava
compromessa ritorniamo di nuovo
sull'argomento
occasione poter ritornare a confrontarsi
dall'altra parte quando non troveremo
nulla di significativo e ci saranno solo
parti aggressive sapremo fare sapete
cosa ignorare di fronte al potere
dell'ignoranza l'auto ronnie a tifà
opporre il potere di ignorare che uno
dei poteri più grandi che abbiamo online
secondo potere che ci da perdere l'ansia
di avere l'ultima parola
quante volte noi vogliamo avere l'ultima
parola
che poi online è ancora più complicato
perché l'ultima parola corrisponde
all'ultima frase che chiude
perfettamente il treno che soddisfazione
si stanno ci sono tutti gli scambi la
mia è l'ultima frase pubblicata
ecco con un po di autoironia e distacco
da se stessi
uno impara che quando ormai si è
spiegato quando ormai ha detto quello
che voleva dire
intanto ha fiducia negli altri che hanno
letto hanno capito non va avanti
all'infinito perché sa che questo non
porta nessuna parte ma prima di finire
c'è un'ultima cosa che voglio dire anche
quel da fuori
lo dobbiamo correggere in senso
autoironico perché pensateci bene dire
guardarsi da fuori è un po stabilire che
c'è un centro che il nostro e poi c'è un
fuori distante c'è un dentro che il
luogo e poi c'è un fuori luogo
c'è un dentro che a fuoco e poi c'è il
fuori cioè fuori ci serve comunque per
avere questo atteggiamento di distanza
una cosa che sta distante quella
differenza che sta sempre un po lì a
disturbarci allora io correggerei questo
guardarsi da fuori e lo prenderei da un
altro punto di vista cioè direi se
vogliamo vivere nel disaccordo mantenere
relazioni pur vedendo le cose
diversamente
quello che dobbiamo fare è sapersi
guardare dal mondo dell'altro
e cos'è il mondo dell'altro nel sistema
delle sue relazioni significative e
quello a cui lui dà valore se ci
connettiamo con quello noi sapremo
riuscire a fare che cosa
a connetterci con la persona che lui è
di abitante di un mondo che per quanto
diverso e persone lo siamo tutti allora
la diversità aumentata non è qualcosa di
artificiale
non è qualcosa che si aggiunge alla
realtà in modo virtuale la differenza
forse è il modo più comune di
presentarsi della nostra realtà così
com'è che è una realtà fatta di mondi
differenti in connessione è l'unico
universo che abbiamo da abitare
grazie
[Applauso]